patients who are using medicinal
marijuana for pain and other chronic
symptoms are getting turned down by
insurers right now
even in states where medicinal marijuana
is legal
the insurers are basically wrote the
coverage because of conflicting laws
because a as far as the FDA is concerned
because if the federal
Drug Administration medicinal marijuana
is not legal so now we have people with
cancer and aids in all kinds of other
right there finding something that is
helping them
and helping them deal with pain and now
again we have the federal government
coming in
and stopping the insurers from allowing
these people to medicate themselves
this to me it is like the worst the word
what I got the impression that it was
the insurance companies choosing not to
know it well it is but he could under
the Don't Know Who I am NOT
yet and because about legal limbo it's
understandable at a big company would
not want to step in the middle love that
until it actually figured out whether or
not you know they are assisting in the
commission of a crime by covering it
with insurance
verses not like thank you for clearing
that up by my
what I would say is you know duh
insurance companies never really do want
to add coverage for things that means
they have to pay out more money they're
not interested in that
know I can see them also saying I will
just wait cuz you know that means that
we have to put up more money for
something
and we're not going to do that I don't
have to right so like everything that
this just come down to money because to
me the FDA loves everything in pill form
and when you have everything in pill
form there's also three minutes a
diarrhea and possible suicide and dad
and all that other
got every whatever are thought you know
other people dancing and they're happy
but they're also having diarrhea and
that the elected
yes ago to sue if they are inevitable
yeah
but so is this partially because
marijuana just doesn't its we don't have
a pill yet we don't have just that
perfect pill
and also that when they win it comes out
one day with you will it's not gonna
have on the side effects because we
doesn't have that
yeah so if this was like a failure a bar
system at the High
I defector I mean it depends on who you
talk to you yeah I get paranoid
upper body and I don't know how much you
use you know for her i'd never be with
anyone smoking weed internet horrible
their
Larry you were lucky there let me tell
you had better have a good week I am
the in the air we didn't recognize you
know what's gonna happen you get laced
with some kinda like you know
been to die as a painter some yeah a so
which the FDA is totally for video that
are helping at that said
yeah I agree on the bathroom I as well
but we have something to give you
yeah exactly there's something that
started benzo that the FDA's for yes
yeah closer a pennzoil it car oil
motor oil I'm well okay yes it is money
does come down to my they're quite Yahoo
spending a thousand dollars a month we
by people who are very thick so yeah if
you're very sick you could be i mean i
know i saw this and I don't mean
in that in that sense like I know a guy
who can cut that in half
for you yeah you get he'll give you as
much as you ever want but like that
seems like a very
large amount you can do it the point if
you're trying to medicate every day
yeah i right I don't get caught the
semantics at hotel but let's talk about
you know if you are somebody who is
truly disabled by some kinda condition
that makes it so you can't work and now
you're gonna be on disability which pays
very little and
the only a medication that gives you any
relief is something that's not covered I
mean I can understand it does put people
who are poor because under disability
into a huge bind
you know I don't know I don't know how
we solve that particular problem because
personally I'm not sure it's a good idea
to get the FDA involved in studying and
testing in approving marijuana because
we've seen what they do with the
pharmaceutical industry
and we see I I decided razor wire where
do you see that go
I don't know cuz if they do I see it
turning into pill form I see it you know
losing its effectiveness I see it being
a
controlled market and that means that
big pharmaceuticals hola
companies will take over and then it
kinda ruined it for everybody as we've
seen what happens with everything when
the suits getting right
okay so I'm on board that so then what
do we do related insurance that sorted
that out there
that you know maybe there's a way for
the had for the federal government to
and the legal limbo aspect and say okay
if you're in a state that has
decided to allow for recreational or
medicine or
marijuana if you're in a state that does
that then we are not going to prosecute
you
and give insurance companies direct and
specific legal guidance that they can
offer that
without themselves getting into some
kind of a
you know accessory related crime right
which going back to previous story that
seems to be in line with the thinking
about Obama and Holder should be brewing
why don't you
they just don't seem to be doing so hot
so a great no i i just think that as far
as the
the drug companies go there that knows
you need to be the people who step up in
make actually affect the product because
for all the people who worked on a lot
of other shit
yeah but you know that it's another
opportunity for them to do something
right or not a horrible I mean they make
a lot of
really good things that help a lot
really im sick people
and I think that they they obviously
wouldn't exist if they were
killing everybody with diarrhea and and
not over time and I
I just want you know I think that as we
go for as things change a little
obviously
in like I said before it's just
something that's or cot in his weird
gray area right now
yeah we're working through I think these
issues what I think one thing that could
be done is when people
make sure that they tell a
representatives at the local state and
national level
we want to make this legal and we want
to and this legal limbo and Congress has
the power to do that more so I think
than
Obama with executive actions he can only
do so much but rather in a bit built
into the law
you know if we demand that ever
representatives you know it it pot there
is a possibility that it could happen
should I guess to get us to demand that
do we need like a George Clooney to jump
on board
publicly instead it seems like we talk
about we do their own you go to the easy
job to get it
you know we talked we go to snoop Dogg
and Willie Nelson
would literally and what he has to do we
need someone like a colony
to to literally get sick
and then be like this is how I'm helping
myself and that that would be the thing
that would get people to realize how
screwed up the system
I think that would help you know I don't
know I'm not wishing to his I don't know
how but I having having and look at me
like i download know you like just
your well right now I think that was not
a shot at you I imagine nothing but help
helping hand to get their guy I've been
preferred not that we're right at the
moment there is this is that this is a
civil libertarian issue and we can all
basically say get the government out of
this particular
out of our lives in this particular area
there now and and just move forward
without you know maybe having a famous
spokesperson a celebrity spokesperson
would would be the trick to help
galvanize people to
to tell the representatives but you know
it's it's taken a long time to even get
to the point where we are now
where we have bring us all they realize
yeah I no i i don't know
got I don't wanna miss merge now be able
to I'd
I think that I i think celebrities doing
things that are political
I hate so much anyway it's like Justin I
roller for me as
time he doesn't watched him the every
single day right so
ira there will be an effective for me it
but I my mind already made up something
I'm not overly good person at
up